Moin Leute, gucken wir mal was Microsoft heute so zeigt, es dauert noch eine halbe Stunde bis es losgeht, wir müssen jetzt gerade mal gucken wo wir am besten gucken, wo gucken wir am besten, ok wir gucken Twitch, da können wir das nämlich wieder in VLC gucken,
oder, ah Moment, Moment, wir gucken ja Microsoft, das heißt wir müssen jetzt auf Mixer gucken oder, gucken wir es auf Mixer, für die originale Microsoft Experience, nur für Erwachsene, na Chat, das wird aber nichts, dann müssen wir auf Twitch gucken,
ne wir gucken das, wir gucken das garantiert nicht auf Mixer, soll ich jetzt nochmal kurz aufs Klo und dann geht es los, so gucken wir mal hier, Twitch, Xbox,
das ist nämlich gut, da können wir das wieder in VLC schauen, ich habe übrigens mein, ich habe mein Meme Board geupgradet, es kann jetzt noch mehr, ups, äh, Desktop, Streamlink, Streamlink, und jetzt Streamlink, Moment, ich muss jetzt erstmal in VLC aufmachen,
Streamlink, Excel, jetzt sehe ich hier unter Windows, so, mal gucken ob es funktioniert,
äh, funktioniert, sehr schön, easy, easy, klar, können wir das zumachen, so, ich zeige euch mal was, also, ich kann es euch nicht zeigen, ich habe jetzt, ich habe mein Meme Tool, habe ich netzwerkfähig gemacht,
ich kann, ich habe jetzt auf dem zweiten, zweiten Rechner, also quasi auch hier auf dem zweiten Monitor, aber das könnte ich auch auf dem Notebook machen, oder theoretisch auch auf einem Tablet, wenn ich, wenn ich mal gucke, wie man das am besten macht,
ne, das Update ist,
das stimmt, so, und, das heißt, ich kann jetzt auf dem zweiten Monitor, kann ich jetzt klicken, und ich habe eine Vorschau an Bildern, kann ich jetzt zum Beispiel hier anklicken, auf dem zweiten Monitor, das heißt, ich muss mir nicht mehr 50 Shortcuts merken, so, erst einmal auf Twitter posten, dass es losgeht, Donation, danke schön, ich muss erst einmal bei mir auf dem zweiten Bildschirm aufmachen, da ich überhaupt was sehe,
Tippi Stream,
437, danke für alles, ja, danke für die Donation,
komm, der E-Axis ist auch am Start,
so,
ähm,
dann machen wir hier mal aus, und machen den VLC an,
gucken schon mal, dass die Lautstärke stimmt,
oh, die Musik,
oh,
hast du schon Battlefield 5 Gameplay geguckt,
von Jackfrax, nein,
sieht besser aus, als der schimmelige Trailer,
ja, der,
was ist das für Musik,
ich habe auch das Gefühl, der Sound ist lauter bei Microsoft,
als gestern bei EA,
ich mache mal kurz einen Ticken leiser,
bis,
bis es losgeht,
da war ich vor der Pulle,
ist wieder Bullshit Bingo am Start,
nee, mir ist irgendwie nichts Gescheites eingefallen,
von Microsoft,
außer, dass Phil Spencer wahrscheinlich wieder ein geiles T-Shirt anhalt,
natürlich war der immer in den besten T-Shirts an,
ich bin begeistert,
wie viele Leute, 22 Uhr,
sind bei uns schon bei, sind heute,
French into K18,
bin ich zu spät, nein, bist du nicht,
es geht noch nicht los,
es geht ab 22 Uhr los,
aber,
nachdem ja anscheinend,
eine ordentliche Zeitzone hier drauf zu schreiben,
zu schwierig ist,
stimmt natürlich keiner der Zeiten,
die hier draufstehen,
also es ist 22 Uhr,
ja,
DE,
G, G, M,
G, S, M,
wie heißt unsere Zeitzone,
Sommerzeit,
ach, keine Ahnung,
GMT plus 2,
Hauptsache 2 mal N,
ey, das kriegen die nicht auf die Reihe,
West Coast, das ist zu kompliziert,
also, ich zeige euch was,
also, ich habe das jetzt abgegradet,
also, gestern hatte ich ja das Problem,
da ich hier zum Einblenden,
musste ich mir ja gestern schon,
irgendwie, 18 verschiedene Shortcuts oder so merken,
und jetzt habe ich hier auf meinem zweiten Monitor
ein Board, wo ich draufklicken kann,
das ist ganz praktisch,
also, ich denke, wir sind jetzt optimal ausgerüstet,
für jegliche Emotionen,
die heute im Livestream auftreten könnten,
ja,
also, ganz wichtig,
wir haben, wenn ein paar Grills am Start sind,
haben wir hier,
hatten wir gestern nicht,
wenn wir klatschen müssen,
haben wir auch was zum Klatschen,
und, was haben wir noch Neues,
Runde Cringe,
hatten wir gestern auch nicht,
Gebated Kappa Pride,
Weep Weep,
Herzchen,
ja, ich habe abgegradet heute,
und ganz wichtig,
das hätten wir gestern bei EA schon gebraucht,
aber das ist bei Microsoft bestimmt auch anwendbar,
haben wir noch was Neues,
gucken,
ich glaube, das war es,
ah ja, und natürlich,
so, also, bis es losgeht,
weil wir haben jetzt noch 20 Minuten Zeit,
müssen wir uns jetzt mal die neuesten PC Master Race Memes angucken,
wenn wir schon dabei sind,
das ist geil,
das habe ich schon mal,
ich habe schon mal,
ich habe schon mal gesehen,
einfach so,
ey, ohne Scheiß, Leute,
so war das wirklich, oder,
2007, beim ersten Crisis,
haben alle Leute gesagt,
boah, ey,
wie geil Spiele bestimmt in den nächsten 10 Jahren aussehen,
und was kommt,
Fortnite,
oder du guckst hier,
wenn uns Battlefield 5 Gameplay hat,
können wir auch machen,
wollen wir Battlefield 5 Gameplay gucken,
ich habe hier eine Playlist vor,
und hier,
jemand hat eine Playlist geschickt,
mit allen,
hat der Mashed 1,
da gucken wir jetzt den,
falls der Mashed 1 hat,
gucken wir den Mashed an,
muss er ein bisschen Werbung machen,
hat der Mashed Battlefield 5 Gameplay,
nein, hat er nicht,
warum nicht,
Finn, was ist da los,
irgendjemand hat auch noch vorhin eine Battlefield 5 Gameplay Liste geschickt,
genau hier,
ah ja,
weil gerade einer schreibt,
was von Realm Royale,
ich habe heute gespielt,
Realm Royale,
ich habe gleich in der dritten Liste,
in der dritten Runde oder so,
habe ich bei Engineer ausgepackt,
und gleich erst der Instant GG Easy Noobs weggepasht,
okay,
Battlefield 5,
was ist denn jetzt bei Microsoft angekündigt,
keine Ahnung,
da müssen wir uns überraschen lassen,
naja,
sie werden wahrscheinlich irgendeine Marke ausbuddeln,
aus ihrem,
ollen Zeug,
und komplett verhunzen,
oder irgendwie sowas wie Scalebound wieder vorstellen,
was dann eingestellt wird,
so,
was gucken wir uns denn für ein Battlefield,
Battlefield 5 Gameplay an,
Grand Operations,
mich interessiert viel mehr Rush,
New Battlefield 5 Early Access Gameplay from E3,
mit Grill,
oh,
Grill,
komm, wir gucken jetzt mal, wie das Grill spielt,
und, aber ich,
die Musik von der Microsoft PK,
das ist ja grausam,
was ist das denn, was da läuft,
das hört sich an wie so Pornmusik, oder,
hört euch das mal an,
Gachi Bass,
was ist das,
Gachi Bass fehlt mir noch als Emote,
kannst du Gaben rotieren lassen,
weil du es bist,
ja, kann ich machen,
da muss, aber,
Achtung, da wird es einem das Epilepsie-Warnung, ja,
da kriegst du echt Kopfschmerzen davon,
Max, kennst du die ganze Geschichte hinter den Gachi Memes,
ist das, ist das nicht aus irgendeinem Porno,
oder war das was anderes,
keine Ahnung,
ich habe irgendwo mal was gelesen,
okay,
Kann auch sein, dass ich es durcheinander bringe.
Max ist Donation angekommen.
Oh, ich habe eine Donation übersehen.
Ja klar, danke für alles.
Habe ich auch vorgelesen.
Danke für die Donation, Alpha.
Alpha X.
Nice.
Übrigens, wenn ich es jetzt tatsächlich mal schaffen sollte,
noch dreimal zu streamen.
Ne, viermal?
Dreimal.
Dreimal zu streamen.
In den nächsten paar Tagen.
Ich meine, der Monat ist noch lang.
Dann darf ich auch wieder Affiliate beantragen.
Ich meine, durfte ich ja schon.
Habe ich ja nicht gemacht.
Dann darf ich es wieder.
Mal gucken, ob ich es diesmal mache.
Okay, gucken wir uns das Video von Jackpacks an.
Aber ohne Gelaber, sondern mit dieser geilen Microsoft-Musik im Hintergrund.
Also, was sehen wir denn hier schon?
Wir sehen Leute, die aus einem Flugzeug springen.
Oder besser gesagt, wahrscheinlich aus einem Heli springen.
Und dass es ein bisschen geruckelt hat, sehen wir.
Und Motion Blur.
Motion Blur ist das Schlimmste.
Was, das kommt aus der Community von Forcen?
Ja, das wundert mich nicht.
Moment.
Jetzt habe ich nicht hingeguckt.
Ist das M-Com direkt unter dem Flugzeug, oder was?
Moment.
Wenn das M-Com direkt unter dem Flugzeug wäre, wäre ich irgendwie bescheuert.
Ach, ne.
Ne, da hat es bloß geschnitten.
So, noch 15 Minuten, dann geht es los.
Demon Rider schreibt,
ähm,
Battlefield 5 sieht für ihn nach einem Battlefield 1 DLC aus.
Finde ich gar nicht.
Ich habe ja Battlefield 1 nicht gespielt.
Ähm, also nur die, nur die Alpha, Beta.
Und da habe ich gedacht, jetzt habe ich keinen Bock auf das Game.
Aber ich finde, es macht einen viel besseren Eindruck als Battlefield 1 auf mich jetzt schon.
Und das, was ich im ersten Trailer gesehen habe.
Ich hoffe, es wird nicht so, irgendwie so, so random irgendwie wie Battlefield 1.
Da bin ich, auf das neue Revive-System bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Ich meine, es kann jetzt im Endeffekt jeder das eigene Squad reviven.
Und, halt, der Medic kann alle reviven halt schneller.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Ich meine, das reviven war, seit, ich meine, in Battlefield 4 ging es noch.
In Battlefield 4 konntest du noch ordentlich Red Strain machen.
Nicht immer ganz so krass wie in Battlefield 3.
Aber ich finde, das ist gerade das, was Battlefield 3 und Bad Company 2 für mich geil gemacht haben.
Dass du halt so richtig schön, äh, Dauer retzen konntest.
Dauerwiederbeleben.
Da haben die Fights einfach länger gedauert und du musstest dir nicht in die Hose machen, dass du irgendwie, dass du verreckst.
Wenn du wusstest, das hat sich halt richtig gelohnt, wenn du ein gutes Team als Backup hattest.
Da wusstest du, hey, selbst wenn ich jetzt verkacke, es retzt mich einer.
Immer.
Ich meine, ich hatte in Bad Company 2 quasi so viele zu Null-Runden, obwohl die überhaupt nicht zu Null waren.
Einfach nur, weil ich ein gutes Team hatte.
Ja gut, so wirklich viel sieht man jetzt auch nicht davon.
Außer, dass Panzer endlich wieder wie Panzer aussehen.
Und ich, die Microsoft-Musik, die macht alles irgendwie ziemlich, äh, ungehypt, oder?
Weggeschneipt.
Den hätte ich auch getroffen, den Schuss.
Mit Ton, ja der, ich will jetzt nicht, äh, quasi mir Jackfrax hier im Stream anhören.
Das gibt's ja noch. Anzeige ist raus, Strike ist raus.
Aber wen das interessiert, der kann sich das Video ja selbst angucken.
Ich meine, ich muss jetzt ja nicht restreamen und ihm quasi Viewer klauen noch.
Auch wenn, wenn die 180 hier jetzt wahrscheinlich auch nicht fett machen bei ihm.
Hat nicht jemand was geschrieben? Es geht angeblich schon irgendwie um halb was los.
So Pre-Show oder sowas.
Aber ich find's gut, dass man die Waffe, dass man so die klassischen, äh, World War 2 Waffen hier wieder am Start hat.
Also MP40, STG, 44, okay, das ist wahrscheinlich irgendein russischer Schneider oder so, keine Ahnung.
Das ist die komische, diese, wie auch immer, Japaner Gun oder wie das, ich weiß nicht, wie das Teil heißt.
Das gibt's aber auch, gab's aber auch in fast allen World War 2 Spielen, das Teil.
Das hat schon in allen Games ein absolut grottiges Ironsight gehabt, dass man's eigentlich nicht spielen will.
Schlimmste Variante war in COD 5, da hast du kaum was gesehen durch das Ironsight von dem Teil.
Bam.
Okay, da sieht man jetzt nicht so viel, es ist halt Kills zusammengeschnitten.
Ja, das neue Revive-Animation.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Dieses realistische Machen von Revives, da weiß ich nicht, ob ich das geil find.
Das von Battlefield 4 war ein ganz guter Kompromiss.
Du konntest schön weit retzen, halt's mal nicht voll, wenn du schnell gehst, aber...
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das so gut finde, wenn die Revives halt ewig dauern, wo dann wieder weniger Leute Medics spielen dadurch.
Und alles irgendwie viel mehr...
...mehr camp-lastig wird, weil sich keiner mehr traut.
So, gleich geht's...ich wollte übrigens noch mal aufs Glowfeld irgendwann ein, aber das muss ich jetzt durchhalten.
So, was haben wir noch? Was haben wir hier sonst noch Battlefield-technisch zu bieten?
Hat der Lost vielleicht...
...eins hochgeladen, weiß ich?
Gucken, der ist ja auch da.
Nö.
Also, ich glaube, dass das Video hier von Lanai...
Lanai? Keine Ahnung.
Lanai.
...dürfte, glaube ich, auch ausführlich sein. Ich meine, das ist einfach eine komplette Runde, 31 Minuten.
Welche Linux-Distribution benutzt du? Ich weiß, dass du gerade auf Windows 10 bist.
Manjaro benutze ich.
Okay, hier sieht man jetzt aber ein bisschen mehr. Das ist einfach Gameplay, das finde ich nicht schlecht.
Da kann man sich...
...schreckt.
Da kann man sich das beste Bild von machen.
Also, einen Rekt-Meme brauche ich noch, das muss ich mal aufschreiben.
Und irgendeinen Gachi-Bass oder sowas.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was Phil Spencer heute für ein T-Shirt anhat.
Ach, hat er das geschrieben?
Warum Embargo und die anderen dürfen?
Das ist auch wieder so zwei...
...zwei Klassen...
...Zeugs da.
Hallo.
Der Chief HB.
Das ist mit der Microsoft-Pornomusik im Hintergrund. Hört sich das so dumm an.
Vor allem hat es Microsoft nötig, da wirklich irgendwie...
Was ist das? Gamerfreie Musik oder was?
Was ist deine Meinung dazu, dass GitHub von Microsoft gekauft wurde?
Erstmal abwarten. Das ist meine Meinung dazu.
Microsoft hat viele Projekte auf GitHub.
Sind, glaube ich, sogar, wenn man rein von Commits und Sourcecodes und so absieht, der größte Open-Source-Contributor mittlerweile der Welt.
Bei Microsoft, muss man sich mal vorstellen, ja.
Das ist die Bill Gates Einschlafmusik.
Das hört sich echt so an.
Das hört sich wirklich...
Ich meine, optisch, ja, aber das hat Battlefield 1 schon auch gemacht, optisch macht das Game wirklich was her.
Oh, die Musik ist vorbei, oder?
Naja, es geht schon wieder los.
Hat das Vorteil, dass du den Stream in VLC guckst?
Ja, ich kann den Vollscreen machen, ohne dass irgendwelche Controls und so eingeblendet werden, wenn ich was drücke.
Es kommt keine Werbung.
Wie sieht eigentlich dein Vorschau-Memeboard aus?
Ja, ich würde es euch gerne zeigen, aber ich habe es auf dem zweiten Rechner.
Kann ich nicht.
Das ist aber ganz billig.
Das ist einfach ein Fenster mit 26 Buttons, wo halt...
...ein Mini-Thumbnail von dem jeweiligen Bild drauf ist.
Ja, das finde ich auch. Die Polarlichter sehen wirklich gut aus.
Wobei, ich glaube, dass solche Sachen...
Die machen zwar immer viel her, aber ich glaube, die sind nicht so schwierig.
Bist du der Einzige...
Ja, ich habe die Musik extra leise, weil das noch Pornomusik ist bei Microsoft im Stream.
Ich mache, sobald es losgeht, mache ich an.
Achso, soll ich übrigens den Chat eingeblendet lassen, oder soll ich den Chat rausmachen?
Wie fandet ihr das gestern?
Ich habe mir das im Nachhinein nochmal angeguckt.
Ich fand das gar nicht so übel mit Chat.
Ist das Zombie-Modus?
Kommt heute wieder ein Blitzeinschlag?
Ich hoffe nicht.
Okay, Chat anlassen. Gut.
Da ist ein Chat an.
Der ist ja nur ganz klein unten rechts in der Ecke.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie Valparaiso an der Stelle, ne?
Guckt mal, das sieht wirklich aus wie Valparaiso an der Stelle.
Wartet mal. Guckt mal. Guckt mal.
Hier hörst du die Hauptstraße. Jetzt musst du ein Stückchen zurück.
Hier geht es hinter zum nächsten M. Komm.
Das sieht wirklich ein bisschen aus.
Und hier rechts hast du den Berg, wo es nicht weiter geht.
Hier kommt die Hauptstraße.
Es hat ein bisschen was von Valparaiso Rush.
Zweite Base.
Bisschen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich sieht die Möbel letztendlich komplett anders aus.
So, machen wir mal ein bisschen lauter, dass wir es nicht verpassen, wenn es anfängt.
Ich mache dann 100% Lautstärke, sobald es losgeht.
Ah, das ist Mitte.
Ach nee, sie erzählen was.
Ich dachte, wir können Ingame-Sound mal hören.
Aber über Sound mache ich mir bei Battlefield keine Gedanken.
Der Sound ist eigentlich immer super.
Die nice Musik, ja.
Richtig geile Musik.
Geht mir voll eine ab bei...
Wissen deine Arbeitskollegen eigentlich von deiner YouTube-Karriere?
Wenn ja, wie stehen die dazu?
Also, die wenigsten wissen das.
Ein paar wissen es.
Und außer, dass man ab und zu ein bisschen was darüber erzählt.
Das ist eigentlich nicht so oft, dass wir darüber...
Das interessiert, denke ich mal, die wenigsten so.
Spiel mal im BDO.
Oh, ich muss noch Daily Rewards abholen.
So, jetzt müsste es gleich losgehen.
Das...
Guckt mal.
Das sieht wirklich aus wie Valparaiso.
Wenn ihr da reinlauft, guckt mal.
Guckt mal.
Hier.
Das ist die...
Hier ist das M-Compt drin normalerweise.
Hier ist die Hauptstraße.
Hier geht es weiter zum nächsten Punkt.
Rechts ist ein Berg.
Gibt es da mal ein Cringe-Meme für die nächste Microsoft-Minecraft-Show?
Haben wir alles am Start heute.
Alles am Start.
Nicht beschweren.
Optionen und Geduldskrieg.
Warum weniger als 5 Tage,
dass ich mehr Zeit für YouTube und Stream
und Zeugs habe?
Das war mal der ursprüngliche Gedanke, als ich das gemacht habe.
Mein YouTube-Video-Output hält sich an Grenzen.
Aus dem Gesichtspunkt wüsste ich das eigentlich nicht machen.
Aber ich sage euch Leute, es ist sehr angenehm,
immer 3 Tage Wochenende zu haben.
Ich habe jetzt immer
Samstag, Sonntag, Montag frei.
Der Gedanke dahinter war eigentlich,
wir müssen mal umschalten, geht gleich los.
Oh, der stand auf Deutsch da gerade.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Sie haben es geschafft.
Okay, gleich geht es los.
Hype intensifies.
Oder auch nicht.
Ich habe nämlich überhaupt keine Ahnung, was uns da erwartet
heute von Microsoft.
Wahrscheinlich Halo 6 oder so.
Nee, warte mal.
Halo 8?
Ich weiß nicht, welcher Halo-Teil wir eigentlich sind.
Halo 25?
Sea of Thieves 2?
Das war...
Schmerz jetzt, ey.
So, es ist 22 Uhr, Leute.
Warum geht es nicht los?
Ah, jetzt geht es los.
So, ich mache volle Pulle-Lautstärke.
So, falls es zu laut, zu leise ist,
sonst was, sagt es einfach.
So, Phil Spencer T-Shirt.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was er anhat.
Game Engine Demonstration.
Ist das ReCore?
Oder wie das hieß?
Das gab es doch schon.
Und das ist gefloppt.
Nee, das ist was anderes.
Monster Hunter Xbox Edition.
Was ist das?
Halo?
Halo!
Ich wusste es.
Halo Battle Royale.
Infinite.
Ich habe keinen Bock, mal zu nommerieren.
Please welcome the head of Xbox, Phil Spencer.
Da ist er.
Was hat er für ein T-Shirt an? Zeig her.
Das ist ja heute ganz normal.
We will join Master Chief on his greatest adventure yet to save humanity.
We are now at a moment of exceptional creativity in gaming.
We can't wait to show you what Creativity Unleashed looks like for you.
Creativity Unleashed?
Die haben es drauf hier.
... in languages.
... in watching us on TV and on Mixer...
Mixer?
Mein Mixer.
Lautstärke okay?
I'd like to personally thank everyone who's joining us from FanFest.
Bitte 10% nach...
100% of the proceeds from your FanFest tickets are going to Gamers Outreach.
So ist besser, ha?
Thanks to you, kids and fans.
und Kinderhospizitäten spielen mit ihren Freunden in ihren Lieblingswelten.
Das ist eine großartige Ausgabe.
Das ist das, was ich am meisten über Spielen mag.
Spielen bringt uns zusammen.
Spielen verbindet uns.
Es inspiriert unsere wahrste Kooperation.
Es schafft einige unserer liebsten Erinnerungen an die Wettbewerbe
und unsere tiefsten Gespräche über die Geschichten in Spielen.
Am meisten ist Spielen eine echte Gemeinschaft.
Es geht um die Ängste, die Fähigkeiten, die Rasse, die Gender und die Geografie.
Deshalb habe ich immer und werde immer glauben,
dass Spielen den großen Unifier ist.
Und was uns unifiziert, ist unsere gemeinsame Liebe zu dieser Kunstform.
Legendäre Charaktere, die uns kaptivieren.
Nicht nur für 10 Stunden, sondern für 10, 20, 30 Jahre.
Weiche Geschichten,
die uns inspirieren,
die uns die Charaktere darstellen.
Iconic Worlds, die so reichlich vorhanden sind.
Wir fühlen Aufregung in der Luft
und Gefahr auf den Seen.
Als Spieler sind wir in einem momentanen Zeitpunkt,
wo kreative Vision und technische Ausgaben zusammen
die Artform, die wir lieben, anbieten.
Also, für Monate haben unsere Teams und ich die Welt gefahren,
die Entwickler aus Japan nach Polen getroffen haben,
von der UK nach der Ukraine,
von großen Studios bis zu einzigen Entwicklern.
Die Kreatoren, die den vollen Kraft und Potenzial von Xbox One sehen,
um ihre berühmte Vision für Spiele zu erzeugen.
Heute haben wir ein besonderes Showcase für ihre besten Arbeit und unseres.
50 Spiele.
18 Titel mit Exklusivität.
Ja, wartet doch erstmal ab!
Ja, wartet dran vier
13.
Ich hab, ich hab jetzt einfach geraten.
Und jetzt doch was anderes, hä?
Ja, das muss Ori sein.
Ja.
Das ist schon mal was Gescheites.
Uncharted 5.
Nein.
Oh.
Irgendwas Japanisches.
Garantiert was Japanisches.
Stealth-Game.
Kokona.
Ein Stealth-Action-RPG im alten Japan.
Interpretiere ich da jetzt mal so rein.
Was Neues.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Wo ist denn...
Alter.
Das war kein Cruiser.
Großer Applaus.
... right after this across the street.
And Phil said to me,
I'm having a few friends over.
Why don't you stop by?
And look, I know Phil is really, really charming.
But damn, he's got a lot of friends.
And the good news is, you're our friends too.
We've had an incredible 16-year history
with Xbox going all the way back to the original with Morrowind.
Now backwards compatible.
And that goes all the way to bringing mods to consoles with Fallout 4.
And now, we are bringing the Fallout universe to Xbox Game Pass with Fallout 4 launching today.
And hey, since we're here, we thought we'd give all of you an exclusive world premiere first look.
Und hey, since we're here, we thought we'd give all of you an exclusive world premiere first look.
... and now, we're bringing the Fallout universe to Xbox Game Pass with Fallout 4 launching today.
... at Fallout 76.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, der Vierer hat mir nicht gefallen.
Yes, Fallout 76 is a prequel to all the other games.
And it is our biggest one yet.
It is four times the size of Fallout 4.
Ja, größer allein macht's nicht aus.
Set in the hills of West Virginia,
you are one of the first to emerge into an untamed and very different wasteland.
Ich meine, 76 ist immer noch besser als 69 für einen Spielname.
Wahrscheinlich dauert es nicht lange nach Release, dass dann irgendwie einer Fallout-69-Porn hochlädt.
Würde mich nicht wundern.
Aber es wurde von euch gebaut, damit, wenn die Bomben kommen, unser Leben überlebt.
Denn wenn die Kämpfe stoppen und die Falle geschlossen sind, musst du wieder bauen.
Nicht nur Wälder, nicht nur Gebäude, sondern Herz und Geister und letztendlich Amerika selbst.
Amerika.
In Vault 76 beginnt unser Zukunft.
Das war schon nah am Debate dran.
Ich werde immer für das Team in der Schule ausgewählt, und sie geben mir nie den Ball.
Sie können nicht Geschichten wie du erzählen, können sie nicht?
Keine Ahnung.
Start the launch.
Zu spät!
Emergency!
Ähm.
Diesmal wirst du von mir nicht weg.
Du wirst es schaffen, es ist alles in Ordnung.
Ich vermisse den Lächeln von Mama.
Ich auch.
Niemandes Freund.
Du wirst wahrscheinlich das Weltleben verändern.
Ich hoffe es.
Ich weiß es.
Captain Spirit ist hier!
Wir haben die Kirche-Vision.
Die tollen Abenteuer von Captain Spirit.
Downloaden Sie gratis vom 26. Juni.
Ähm.
Okay.
Fällt mir nichts zu ein.
Großartig. Mal gucken, was es ist am Ende.
Commander Jackson, auf dem Tod.
Willkommen bei Crackdown 3.
Das einzige Spiel, das wie ich gebaut wurde.
Großartig, wunderschön.
Wie ein Skyscraper.
Es fällt dir auf den Kopf.
Wenn du auf meinem Niveau spielen willst, folge meinem Leak.
Jemand, gib mir mein Geheimnis!
Ja!
Es geht nur darum, auf den Feind zu springen.
Kein Bildung ist zu hoch.
60 Jahre oben,
Aufkommen!
Keine mehr.
Niemals, niemals, niemals.
Niemals.
Ja, doch.
Dann brauch ich das Spiel!
Mit einem Schuss auf den Kopf!
Warte!
Dann brauch ich das Spiel!
Nein!
wann war ich denn auf der Gamescom
bei der Microsoft? Lass mal überlegen.
Das war 2015?
2016 oder so?
Ja.
Da hab ich sogar noch ein T-Shirt.
Hier, dachte schon längst raus.
Februar 2019.
Ey, das haben die doch schon ewig angekündigt.
Okay.
Ist das ein Add-on?
Ist das ein Metro?
Ne.
Doch, das ist ein Metro, oder?
Ja, das ist Metro.
Klar ist es Metro.
Also spätestens bei dem Namen weiß man es jetzt.
Davon kann es ruhig noch einen Teil geben.
Die waren alle ganz gut.
We'll get it.
We'll cross it, no matter what those fanatics think.
If the heretics come for our lives,
we will stand firm.
Dark heretics.
Artyom, jump!
Nice.
Das kann kommen.
Nächstes Jahr,
dreiviertel Jahr hin.
Aber davon,
die haben alle gut, die Games.
Da kann es ruhig noch ein neues geben.
Die nächsten Spiele schauen und spielen am besten auf der Xbox One.
Okay.
Hätte ich jetzt genauso gut auch nicht sagen können.
Wie die nächsten Spiele.
Die Generationen lieben Roll-Playing-Spiele von Inventive Studios in Japan.
Unsere nächste Spiele sind die neuesten in einer legendären Serie.
Für das erste Mal auf der Xbox.
Kingdom Hearts.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Ja.
Es kalt.
Jesse und die beiden sind auf der Bühne.
Hey, Islander, was kann ich sagen?
Guck mal.
Selbst die Seele wird auf Eis gewechselt.
Wow.
Du bist wirklich lebendig.
Hallo.
Olaf, sind das deine Freunde?
Hm?
Nein, ich habe ihn nie gesehen.
Ich kenne niemanden, der auf diesen Spielen blutig-grün ist.
Ah!
Ja!
Es ruckelt.
Gib mir Kraft!
Es ruckelt die ganze Zeit.
Es ist nicht, dass du lebst, das Game.
Ja!
Da war Ralf.
Das ist großartig.
Du kannst Eis kontrollieren.
Kontrollieren?
Nein, ich mache immer nur Menschen schmerzen.
Das ist mein Haus jetzt.
Ich kann nicht zurück.
Ich will niemanden schmerzen.
Herc!
Schau auf!
Ah!
Utm.
Roxas existiert.
Sein Herz ist innerhalb meines.
Das andere Down In hallway ist nur Daten.
Und was wird Elise dann?
Ich blicke bei Kingdom Hearts nicht durch von der Reihenfolge der Games.
Das ist zu hoch für mich.
Okay, das ist jetzt der dritte Teil.
Weil es gab ja auch irgendwie 2,5 oder so.
Das hieß ja wirklich 2,5.
Also bei Kingdom Hearts ist es mir zu hoch.
Dann steige ich mal durch, was da in welcher Reihenfolge.
Oh nein.
Ich zunehmend gerade so als wäre das der Wahnsinn Erfolg gewesen.
Okay.
Ich muss auch ehrlich sagen, der Arztteil von Sea of Thieves hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen.
Er hat ein bisschen einen Unfall erreicht.
Ich denke, er braucht nur einen Moment, um sich zu kühlen.
Jetzt.
Ich spüre, dass du mir etwas zum Inspektieren gebracht hast.
Zeig es mir.
Die Wälder der Veränderung rollen durch die Seen.
Und ein neues Land wird entdeckt.
Die versagten Schuhe.
Ein Ort der Dunkelheit.
Wo?
Wo Feuer und Steine alle entdeckt werden.
Und aus der Tiefe werden Skeletonschiffen aufwachsen, um die Seen zu verurteilen.
Ein altartiges Schicksal, das auf dem See der Thieves losgelassen wird.
Du hast mir das Wichtigste getragen, was das Schrecklichste ist.
Du wolltest nur wissen, wie viel es wert war, oder?
Nein.
Ja, ja, das ist Battlefield.
Finish in 2K17.
Äh, 18.
19.
Äh, ja.
Und weiter.
Explosive World Premiere.
Puppke.
Nein.
Zum Glück nicht Puppke.
Weil er halt vor sah.
Minecraft kommt bestimmt auch noch.
Nee, das interessiert mich nicht.
Soll der wirklich was taugen für Leute, die auf Rennspiele stehen?
Ist überhaupt nicht meins.
Die hätten ruhig ein bisschen mehr zu Battlefield zeigen können.
Da hast du ja nichts gesehen.
Hm.
Autos.
Die fahren.
Hat's doch nie gegeb'n.
World first.
Pre-, Premiere.
Fahrende Autos.
Nicht mein Fall.
Ich will jetzt auch nicht schlecht reden oder so, weil die Serie muss wirklich gut sein für Leute, die halt auf sowas stehen.
Please welcome from Playground Games, Ralph Fulton.
Das einzige, was EA gestern nicht geschafft hat, ist, random Auto fährt über die Bühne.
Vielleicht schafft das Microsoft ja heute.
Hi Bill.
Und bitte begrüßen Sie Andy, der offroad-Buggy perfekt ist, um Jumps zu nehmen, rocky Terrain zu skalieren und Spaß auf der Britten-Kostellinie zu haben.
Aber zuerst, lasst uns Rebekka mitnehmen.
Sie genießt den Sommer in ihrer hochkustomisierten Nissan Silvia.
Der Sonn ist aus, der Himmel ist blau und es ist der perfekte Trend für das Rennen.
Forza Horizon Force Britain ist ein gemeinsames, offenes Werkzeug.
Wenn du spielst, spielst du mit der gesamten Gemeinschaft.
Und das bedeutet, dass die anderen Fahrer, die du im Spiel treffen wirst, reale Menschen werden, mit all der Vielfalt, Spontaneität und Spaß, die reale Menschen bringen.
Lasst uns Bill mitnehmen.
Er ist in dem gleichen gemeinsamen Weltraum wie Rebekka, fährt auf Geschwindigkeiten, die noch mehr Spannung an Xbox One X von der brandneuen 60 FPS-Mode machen.
Ist das neu?
Ernst gemeinte Frage, mit was liefen die anderen?
Das ist so action-packed.
Everything.
In Horizon 4, every season changes the world around you, with each bringing its own unique beauty and unique gameplay.
One of the great things...
One of the great things about this shared world is that it's easy to interact with the people you meet.
Ja, wie in echt.
Da bleibe ich auch immer mit Sportwagen auf der Straße, sehe und sage Hallo aus dem Auto raus.
...to start a new friendship.
It looks like Rebekka has found some like-minded friends.
It's great to play solo, but it's better to play with others.
Horizon 4 lets you seamlessly enter co-op from within the game world.
Seasons, time of day and weather conditions are dynamic, but they are synchronized for every player, so the entire community will experience them at the same time.
Ich meine, es macht was her.
Da kann man nichts gegen sagen.
Let's see how this scene looks in winter.
Aber die vergangenen Teile haben mich nicht interessiert.
Und das interessiert mich auch nicht.
Aber das ist halt safe cash-crab für Microsoft, das Ding.
Ey, der Effekt passt richtig gut dazu.
Nicht nur Microsoft kann Blätter fallen lassen, ich kann das auch.
Das Schaf wurde gerade übelst gereckt.
Und das ist auch nicht so einfach, um große Rewarden zu gewinnen.
Und während sie das Event anfangen, möchte ich euch zeigen, wie die Welt von Forza Horizon 4 im Frühjahr aussieht.
Wieder einmal verändert sich die Welt komplett mit den Saisons, bringt neue Fahrer-Erlebnisse, neues Spielzeug und neue Events über die ganze Welt.
Jede Saison gibt es neue Gründe, Forza Horizon 4 zu spielen.
Und die große, kreative, lustige Horizon-Gemeinschaft, die sich über die ganze Welt befindet, wird immer größer.
Tage.
Ich warte noch auf den
Slow-Motion-Kar-Dor-Breach
oder sowas.
Thrills.
Okay, das hat mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt
überhaupt nicht gejuckt.
Wie die alle ausrasten,
wenn er auf die Bühne kommt.
Was geht ab?
Das Gleiche hat er eben
schon mal gesagt.
Der sagt,
jedes Mal das Gleiche.
Das hat er eben
auch schon mal gesagt.
Genau das Gleiche.
Ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Der war jetzt dreimal auf der Bühne
und hat dreimal das Gleiche gesagt.
Der war jetzt dreimal auf der Bühne und hat dreimal das Gleiche gesagt.
This new Santa Monica studio is building a team of world-class talent to create groundbreaking
new game experiences.
Was denke ich da aber?
I'm excited to welcome Undead Labs to Microsoft Studios.
This studio caught our attention with their visionary approach to building a zombie survival
franchise.
Oh, das gab's ja noch nie.
They just released their second infestation into the world and in the first two weeks
over two million of you have joined the fight to survive.
Now, it's my distinct pleasure to announce that we have acquired Playground Games.
Haben wir wirklich noch mehr Zombie-Survival gebraucht?
This is one of the highest rated studios of this generation, celebrated for their incredible
craftsmanship.
Not only will Playground Games be a part of this, but they will also be a part of the
future.
As Playground Games continue to work on Forza Horizon, they're bringing their open world
expertise to an entirely new project.
We can't wait to share more about that later.
And for the fourth new studio, it's my personal honor to welcome Ninja Theory to Microsoft
Studios.
Von denen habe ich ein Game gespielt, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die noch mehr Games haben.
Das fand ich aber storytechnisch echt gut.
When we collaborated on Kung Fu Chaos back on the original Xbox, and a minute into playing
Hellblade, you know you're in the hands of master storytellers, who are fearless about
telling bold, cinematic stories.
Also, die Story von Hellblade hat mir wirklich gefallen.
This is a team's gift in creating new franchises.
And yes, we've got a fit studio to announce, Compulsion Games.
Two years ago, we premiered a game.
We couldn't get out of our heads.
A game that captivated us with its strong, fresh and intense storytelling.
We Happy Few is nearing its full release and to gamers everywhere.
Okay, es ist noch nicht gefloppt, aber ich bin da mal gespannt.
Ich hab's schon voll abgehackt im Kopf.
Ich dachte, es ist schon längst raus und keiner spielt's mehr.
By joining us at Microsoft Studios, these five new teams will have the chance to play in
the future.
So, please help me in welcoming all of our new studios.
Our teams will have the resources, the platform and creative independence to take bigger
risks, create even bolder worlds for you.
Wir hatten noch keine Frau auf der Bühne.
Truth is the enemy of happiness.
Das geht aber nicht im Jahr 2018.
Isn't that the decision we all made?
Oh, but you know the truth, don't you?
There's not a thing I can tell you that you don't already know.
Is there?
Have you had your joy, Ollie?
People in town are getting a tad bit skinny.
I think they're starving to death and they're painting the streets with f***ing rainbows.
Have you not noticed?
Oh, Ollie.
Why are you all wearing those ridiculous new masks?
You should get one.
They shape your face into a smile and when you smile, you can't help being happy.
We have to tell people.
They need to know the truth.
No.
It's better not to know.
Das haben wir aber auch schon gefühlt 50 Mal gesehen, so was in der Richtung von dem Game.
We're practically the only two people in this entire city not stoned out of our minds on joy.
It's not a lovely day for it.
It's a f***ing terrible day for it.
If you force people to have the emotions you want, then you turn them into f***ing robots made out of meat.
Where is it?
Where's the blackberry?
You've gone too far this time.
People won't face facts.
Not until we take their joy.
And when we do that, they'll murder each other in the street.
Das haben sie auch schon vor Ewigkeiten angekündigt.
Exklusiv.
Puppke.
Warum ist das Exklusiv?
Kann mir irgendjemand erklären, warum das Exklusiv ist?
Warum haben die Exk...
Warum...
Warum sagen die davor Exklusiv?
Auf der Konsole Exklusiv.
Puppke.
Das ist halt Puppke.
No aim, no brain, shotgun main.
Long.
Also quasi so wie in dem Trailer ist das Spiel halt nicht, ne?
Ich glaub das...
Das Gameplay im Trailer hatte mal nichts mit dem echten Gameplay zu tun.
Fable?
Nein.
Äh, Tales of...
Vesperia?
Irgendein Tales of.
Irgendein Tales of ist das.
Vesperia, ja.
Wer auf JRPGs steht, sollte das spielen, das war echt nicht übel.
Und es ist die Version mit allem dabei, wie's aussieht.
Weil dieses...
Dieses Piraten-Grill...
War in der ursprünglichen Xbox-Version nicht dabei.
Warum weiß ich das eigentlich?
Beziehungsweise immer noch?
Wie Read Me Spam und Baka If Ban.
Definitive Edition.
Könnte man eigentlich mal wieder spielen.
Wie gesagt, ich fand's nicht schlecht.
Das ist ja von 2000...
Was?
Keine Ahnung, 2013 oder so.
Die Vision?
Ist die Vision?
Oder?
Ist das die Vision?
Wobei...
Der Mann sieht so aus.
Aber nichts hat das Virus beendet.
27 Tage nach Patient Zero...
...fiel Washington.
Es begann mit Ritualen auf K-Street.
Dann Schüsse im Nationalmall.
Truppen flogen in Bunker.
Zivilisten wurden in den Straßen verlassen.
Amerika ist auf der Brücke des Verbrechens.
Aber einige Menschen haben überlebt.
Gärten wachsen auf Rüfteln.
Ihre Fenster werden mit Pfeifen betrachtet.
In Gemeinschaften, die unter ständigem Verbrechen leben.
Überleben hat die Form von urbanem Krieg genommen.
Jahrhunderte lang.
Auf diesem ganzen Boden.
Bruder gegen Bruder.
Blut ausgespült, um die Vereinigten Staaten zu fordern.
Die Geschichte ist anstrengend, sich zu erneuern.
Jetzt, im Wärme des Sommers.
6 Monate nach dem Ausbruch.
Eine Rettung eines korrupten Staates fliegt in die Schatten.
Wird es Zombie-Überwachung sein?
In einer neuen zivilen Krieg.
Die Agente der Division sind die Einzigen...
...die sterben.
Aber wie rettest du eine Nation...
...wenn ihre Feinde aus dem Inneren kommen?
Ja doch, die Division.
Weißt doch.
Hab ich beim ersten Bild schon gesagt.
Da haben sie mich übelst gebetet zwischendurch.
Ich dachte beim ersten Bild so...
...Division.
Und dann so...
...oder doch nicht?
Oder doch nicht?
Am Ende ja doch, Division.
Far Cry 25.
Nein, Division Gameplay.
Du, Kit.
Hattet ihr das gehört?
Ja.
Näher zu dieser Zeit.
Ähm...
Die, die da im Hintergrund labern...
...soll das...
...soll das ingame gelabert sein?
Oder soll das so...
...Fake...
...Fake TeamSpeak Discord gelabert sein während der Mission?
Ich glaube, dass...
Die beiden kommen oder was?
Ja, da soll Discord...
Oh Gott!
Ist klar!
So rede ich auch immer online, wenn ich irgendeine Mission spiele.
Ja?
Was soll TeamSpeak sein?
Obzieh, so ein Discord?
Carpinski, it's the Division.
Hey, let me just talk to this guy.
I'm glad to see you.
We got a boy here who's gonna die without his meds.
Those true sons of assholes confiscated them.
Along with most of our drinking water.
Up around P.E.A.S.
Oh, hey.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Hey, hey, hey.
Okay, meet us at the sinkhole?
Yep.
Okay, sure.
So redet man auch immer, wenn man online spielt.
Okay.
Definitely.
Das ist ja schon so halb roleplaying.
If you want a new side mission on the map.
Yeah, we're not that far.
Okay, do it after the crash site?
Sounds good.
They're just ahead of us, Matt.
Und, zumindest halten sie...
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Hey, hey, hey.
Und zumindest halten sie Megan, Kit und Duke.
Also Nix, X, HD, Quickscope, I sniped, HD.
Megan, Kit, Duke.
Eigentlich fehlt jetzt noch irgendwie zwei Russen im Team oder so, die sich weigern Englisch
zu sprechen, bloß noch ein Franzose, der auch nicht Englisch sprechen kann, um die
quasi echte Experience zu zeigen.
Das erinnert mich ziemlich an das erste Gameplay vom ersten Division, was sie gezeigt haben.
Gut, es war auch in der Stadt, aber es war genau so aufgebaut.
Und am Ende sah es dann zumindest nicht so aus.
Ja, das ist der Ingenieur.
In-Game-Chat.
Max FTW I, das soll der In-Game-Chat sein, ist klar, voll wie in echt.
Das ist quasi der Trailer von Division 1, bloß dass es jetzt um ein Flugzeug geht.
What?
Der ist jetzt da nicht rausgekommen aus dem Stein, aber wenn man draufschießt, ist es
gut, oder was?
Juggernaut.
Oh, crap.
Warum muss der Kot mit sowas anfangen?
Jetzt muss ich euch mal sagen, das Team hat mal mega NA-Aim, das ist an NA-Aim kaum zu
überbieten.
Und absoluten Movement-Grüppel, ey.
Haben die Leute schon mal an Shooter gespielt, oder so?
Nice.
Let's check it out.
Great idea.
Let's just die.
So, game plan.
Take the capital back.
I think we're ready.
3, 2, 1, do, do, do, do, do, do!
Genau, so läuft es in echt auch immer im Team-Speak ab.
Yeah, please welcome the head of Engineering, Xbox Game Pass, Ashley Spiker.
Ashley Spiker.
Jawohl, ja.
Oh, krass.
Nice.
Endlich haben wir mal ein Grill auf der Bühne.
Das Problem ist, dass Game Pass sackt.
Wie soll ein maschinelles Lernen meine Spiele?
Also ich meine, außer dass man das im Voraus lädt, weil es errät, was ich als nächstes spielen will.
Aber ich meine...
Ja gut, das Spiel ist gut.
Das Spiel startet jetzt halt schneller, wenn ich Glück habe, dass die AI denkt, dass ich das spielen will.
Ja okay.
Nice.
Da hat sie recht.
Das Spiel startet jetzt halt schneller, wenn ich Glück habe, dass die AI denkt, dass ich das spielen will.
Games like Ashen, Warhammer Vermintide 2, Afterparty und Phoenix Point, all available in Xbox Game Pass the same day as their global release.
So, that's what's next.
But let's talk about what's happening.
But let's talk about what's happening today.
Tom Clancy's The Division.
The Elder Scrolls Online Tamriel Unlimited.
And Fallout 4.
Okay, sie erzählen uns jetzt was, warum Game Pass nicht ganz so sinnlos ist, oder wie?
Und jeder, der das spielen will, hat es doch schon längst.
Today in Xbox Game Pass.
Ich erzähle euch danach mal gleich was zu den Klatschern, wenn wir fertig sind.
Thank you to all of the developers working with us to bring freedom of choice to gamers
around the world.
Vielleicht habt ihr auch schon mal die Ehre, Microsoft-Vor-Klatscher zu sein.
Thanks, everyone.
Aha, das ist Afterparty.
Noch nie gehört.
Golf!
Yeah!
Endlich!
Digga, Wutz!
Ist das...
For Honor?
Nur noch schlechter, oder was war das gerade?
For Honor mit dedicated Server.
Battle Royale Spiel!
Geh weg!
Schon mal besser als EA gestern.
Okay.
Was habe ich jetzt getan?
Oh, dass es nicht praktisch ist.
Ich weiß, dass es schwer ist, es zu glauben.
Du musst mich vertrauen.
Wir müssen uns gegenseitig vertrauen.
Er will den Weg der Menschheit ändern.
Wenn du diese Macht hättest, was würdest du tun?
Was はっ?
Tony Hawk's Pro Skater NG 3.0
3.0
Session
Man hat einen Null vom Gameplay gesehen jetzt.
Aber das scheint ja eh nicht mal angesagt zu sein, dass man Gameplay zeigt.
Oh nein, das ist BDO.
Das ist BDO.
Oh, da geht der...
Der Fabian macht schon einen neuen Account, sage ich euch.
Oh.
Der Fabian macht schon einen neuen Account.
Ich weiß das jetzt schon.
Wenn das bis dahin ausspielt.
Aber schön.
Schönen Store hat das Game.
Also lasst euch nichts erzählen.
Das Spiel hat keine Story, ne?
Also ich habe das schon einige Stunden gespielt.
Ich weiß, das hat keine Story.
Vergesst es einfach.
Das ist ein...
Ein MMO aus Korea.
Das ist ein MMO aus Korea.
Im Prinzip cry mit man da den ganzen Tag.
Wenn einem das gefällt, ist das super.
Und alle Charaktere schreien so rum, standardmäßig.
Wenn ihr euch nicht verletzt, dann lernt ihr euren echten, rechten Selbst.
Seht, ich bin ein Lesra.
Die Dunkelheit, die aus dem Desert geboren wird.
Na gut.
Warum nicht?
Wir müssen auch gucken, wo sie bleiben.
Red Dead Redemption?
Oder?
Nein.
Ich dachte, es war so Cowboy-mäßig.
Ja, es ist Devil May Cry.
Wenn man den Typ gesehen hat, wusste man das.
Geil.
Ich meine, der junge Dante ist schon...
Ja, schon ziemlich kapperfrei.
Okay.
Sie nehmen das?
Ja, er ist ein echter Pro, wenn er Dämonen herumschmeckt.
Deswegen biete ich ihm diesen gut funktionierenden Arm, um Dämonen-A***n zu schlagen.
Was? Kein Chit-Chat oder Monolog?
Einfach ganz richtig zu den Punkte gehen, oder?
Ich will ein Hase.
Wie erwartest du das so viel?
Mein kreaturer, unglaubliches Arbeit ist immer wert.
Du weißt es.
Hase!
Ja, garantiert der Film-Matecry.
Ich dachte, glaube ich, sogar schon da.
Bitte willkommen von Capcom, Produzent Matt Walker und Direktor Hideaki Itsuno.
Als Direktor habe ich vier Jahre gedauert, bis ich das habe.
Danke vielmals.
Die MC ist zurück.
Englisch ist hart.
Das ist einfach nicht einfach.
Es sind zehn Jahre her, seit Devil May Cry 4 veröffentlicht wurde.
Und die Fans haben gefragt, ob es einen echten Sequel gibt.
Also, das ist hart.
Laut und klar.
Wir hören dich.
Devil May Cry und Hideaki Itsuno sind zurück.
Am Anfang war es so, dass ich mich nicht mehr so gut fühlte.
Es war so, dass ich mich nicht mehr so gut fühlte.
Im Entwicklung des Devil May Cry 5 setzten wir unsere Augen darauf, etwas zu erschaffen,
das world-class Visuals haben würde.
Wir haben also volle Kostüm-Modelle für alle unsere Hauptcharaktere gescannt.
Und mit der Kraft des Xbox One X können wir sie so realistisch wie möglich errichten.
Jetzt, obwohl Visuals wirklich wichtig sind, müssen die Kontrollen auch ständig und anspannend bleiben.
Wir haben also die besten Gedanken bei Capcom gesammelt, um sicherzustellen,
dass wir immer noch das großartige Spiele geben können, das Devil May Cry nicht.
Okay.
Marketing, bla bla bla.
Was?
Ja, natürlich, was sonst?
Es ist immer best of all time
und das Beste, was wir je gemacht haben.
So ist es.
Ja, Patrick, du hast schon recht.
Exclusive.
Jetzt kommt Minecraft.
Nein.
Moment.
Das gibt es doch schon.
Das ist ein Add-on, hä?
Das ist ein Add-on?
Also auf jeden Fall DLC-Content.
In das Game muss so unglaublich viel Arbeit geflossen sein,
dass ich mir das kaum vorstellen kann, ehrlich gesagt.
Da geht es.
Da gab es das auf der Xbox.
Zelda mit Fuchs?
Ja, das hat schon starke Zelda-Anleihen.
Also zumindest so
von dem grünen Dichtwasser an hat,
von dem Schild, von...
Der Rest nicht so wirklich.
Tunic.
Ähm.
Er sagt ja schon wieder das Gleiche.
Only in our shared experience.
Sharing the same world.
The same seasons.
the same campaigns and there's real meaning in sharing our love of gaming
with fellow gamers. This community is the reason why we love premiering games
here at E3. For the rest of our briefing, everything you show you will be world
premier games no one has seen before. Starting off with something entirely new
from our friends at Bandai Namco. On my last trip to Japan, their creative team
showed me a sneak peek at their next game. Now you get to see the first look.
World Premiere.
There are worlds that exist separate from our own.
Wie lange geht denn das, ey? Der Wahnsinn.
Where the impossible is reality.
Both good and evil.
These worlds were never meant to meet.
But things have changed.
Now they have begun to merge as one.
And our last hope are the heroes we could only imagine.
United to fight for our survival.
Trangonborn.
Trangball.
Cross Over.
Trangball, Naruto, Cross Over.
Ok.
Alien USA.
Aha.
Jump Force.
Unite to fight.
Ok halt, Prügel-Spiel.
Prügel-Royal-Spiel.
Hört uns ab, wie die schaffen das überall einzubauen.
Heraklitus.
Homefront 4.
Ich habe noch keine Zombies gesehen.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Keine Zombies ist gut.
Okay.
Was geht, Chris?
At the same time...
Wir haben es den ersten Teil in Deutschland.
...how it plays to the events that occur.
Everything in the game world can change
based on...
...in your decisions.
The following demo throws a bit more light on this.
Die haben aber heute ganz schönes Programm,
muss man echt sagen.
Von 22 Uhr bis jetzt 23 Uhr fast 30.
Die sind ja immer fertig.
Die wollen es wissen.
Dying Light 2 features a functioning ecosystem
that reacts on multiple levels
to the things you do
and the choices you make.
In the example we are about to show you,
our protagonist undertakes a mission for the Peacekeepers,
one of the many factions active in the city.
They want you to negotiate with two survivors
who are controlling and hoarding a water supply.
You're going to solve this with another...
Let's say you choose to carry out the Peacekeepers' orders
one way or another.
After this you will start seeing a significant change in the city
as access to the water supply allows the Peacekeepers...
I can at least say I've played the first part already.
...there's even running water for the people at the street level
and that raises their morale
and allows you to replenish your energy on the go.
Have you played the first part?
But there's a cost to this.
So how similar is it to the first part?
The peacekeepers have a richer approach to law and order.
So while the streets may be safer,
it's only safer for those who side with them.
So if you get on their bad side...
...now let's return to that...
This is a moment of choice.
And instead of killing them,
you choose to team up with this group
to supply water on the black market.
As you will see, this creates a very different set of consequences for the city.
With water being a precious currency,
it brings you access to new resources and trade.
But this in turn attracts the worst type of people to the area.
And this is just a single decision.
One out of hundreds you will have to make.
But it allows you to carve out your own world.
Each player's game experience will be unique.
And by the way, this is just what happens in the day.
At night, well, things tend to get a lot darker.
Also doch Zombies.
World premiere.
A lot of time has passed.
You've gotten soft.
And complacent.
You always knew this day would come.
You always knew the three of you would be needed again.
You always...
Wait, what?
Wusste gar nicht, dass es die Marke überhaupt noch gibt.
Body morphing genre mashups.
Three player couch co-op.
4K hand drawn 2.5D graphics.
And broad, non-specific feature declarations.
They're back.
Wusste... Gab es...
Also ich kenne nur das Original auf dem Super Nintendo.
Wusste gar nicht, dass es dazwischen noch was gab.
Oder gab es dazwischen noch was?
World premiere.
I was born to fight wars that no army could win.
There was no fear.
No failure.
Far Cry 8.
Nein, Just Cause.
The rules have changed.
Just Cause? Nein.
The enemy changed.
Okay, raten wir mal ein bisschen weiter.
And no one was ready for it.
Just Cause?
Ich tippe...
They are the world's most powerful private army.
But even they should fear what they've created.
This is in a war, Rico.
This is survival.
Jaja, Just Cause.
Muss.
Jaja, eindeutig.
Want me getting shot at?
Ich muss jetzt mal in den Spielverderber...
äh...
spielen.
Ich fand's langweilig.
Das ist doch ein Game gewesen, das konntest du drei, vier Stunden spielen und dann war's...
Aber ich fand's langweilig.
Okay, wenn ich in den Chat gucke, ich bin nicht der Einzige, dem's so geht.
Aber ich fand's wirklich langweilig.
Das war überhaupt nicht meins.
World premiere.
Da wird ja premiered heut hier.
Ey, gehst vor.
Gehst vor.
Ach da.
Ach.
Da fuck.
What?
Es gibt, es gibt jetzt...
Okay, das ist irgendein Merchandise Zeug, oder?
Hier, es gibt jetzt, es gibt jetzt Gears of War Figuren.
Gears Royale, genau.
Gears Royale.
Das war Gears Royale.
Gears of War zur realistischen Grafik, das kommt beim Battle Royale Games nicht gut an.
Das war das neue Gears Royale, genau.
Oh, Gott.
Was ist das?
Das sieht nicht gut aus.
Also ich meine,
ein Gears of War Strategiespiel
kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Aber das, was man da gerade gesehen hat,
sah jetzt nicht sonderlich,
wie soll ich sagen,
wie ich mir ein Strategiespiel
auf dem PC vorstelle aus.
Ja dann.
Ich bin ganz ohr,
zeig mal her.
Gears of War.
As Kate, you'll journey across
the biggest and most beautiful world
we've ever created.
With the war for humanity escalates
on two fronts, outside of the capital city
and within Kate herself.
In this moment from the game,
Kate leads a rescue message
to a remote village,
but something goes horribly wrong.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Das passiert ja nie.
Kate.
No, no, no, no.
Kate, Kate, you can't see this.
You don't see this.
Sie sieht bloß als Soldat
irgendwie in dieser Einheit
50 Milliarden durchgeschnittene Leute
mit der Kettensäge,
aber den einen Ding, der, das geht nicht.
I'm not going.
Excuse me?
For months now I've been having these dreams.
Nightmares.
But I think they were messages.
Something's happening to me.
Hey, er ist auch wieder am Start.
It's your grandmother's.
Enough, we'll deal with this later.
Fass round these people up.
I need help.
There's a place.
Up north.
I think,
we can find you answers there.
No.
Absolutely not.
We have orders.
You'll go with me?
God damn it, both of you, listen.
I'll go with her.
Look, if you're missing, general notice.
Okay.
I'll push Jack to coordinates.
No, Corporal.
You're coming back to North Vera.
That is a direct order.
Well, Captain.
Screw your order.
This isn't about you.
It's about me.
I need to fix this.
Was ist das eigentlich für eine Armee?
Hey, watch her.
Her necklace?
That's a locust symbol.
Yes.
So.
She would never be our enemy by choice.
I know that.
Because she would die for us.
But what if it's not her choice?
Ich hoffe, wir müssen uns nicht noch mehr mit Markus Felix rumquillen.
So gut ich es so vorfande...
Markus Felix ist auch schlechteste Actionheld in allen...
...Games irgendwie.
Das ist so der genericste Actionheld aller Zeiten.
Das Spiel ist super.
Gibt's nichts dagegen zu sagen.
Den Fehler, den sie meiner Ansicht nach gemacht haben, ist, dass sie so sehr auf...
...gefühlsmäßig machen in Gears of War.
Und die Charaktere halt absolut keine Tiefe haben.
Hey, hey.
What are you...
Why did you come here with me?
What did JD tell you?
This is why you...
...game up so hard.
You're not gonna make it.
Gut, mal gucken wie es wird.
2019.
Die kündigen verdammt viel für 2019 an.
Ich mein, ist klar, sie müssen Zeug da noch entwickeln.
Aber so ein bisschen was dieses Jahr auf der Xbox...
In the entire history of Xbox...
...hätte auch noch was.
...in the entire history of E3...
...in the entire history of our industry...
...gaming is now at its most vibrant.
Der erzählt...
Today we shared our commitment to giving you the freedom...
...to discover and play all of the great games...
...all of the great new games...
Alles, was der heute den ganzen Abend gesagt hat...
...hätte er in drei Sätzen sagen können.
...today we showcased more games...
...than we ever have before.
...50 games...
...18 titles with exclusivity...
...and 15 world premieres.
Aber dieses Jahr ist ein bisschen wenig.
...today we shared...
...our most diverse gaming portfolio...
...in every measure.
...from breadth and art style...
...genre and cultures...
...object and setting...
...scale and story...
...and scope and creative vision.
...and every one of these plays best on Xbox.
...the world of gaming is on an historic growth path...
...where the increasing number of gamers...
...is met with the increasing creative power...
...of game developers.
...in this significant moment...
...we are constantly challenging ourselves...
...where can we take gaming next?
...our answer?
...we commit and harness...
...the full breadth of our resources at Microsoft...
...to deliver on the future of play.
...our experts in Microsoft research...
...are developing the future of gaming AI.
...so the worlds and characters...
...we enjoy will be even more rich...
...and more immersive.
...our clouded worlds...
...are building a game streaming network...
...to unlock console quality gaming...
...on any device.
...we are dedicated...
...to protecting your experience...
...everywhere you want to play.
...on your Xbox, your PC, or your phone.
...and of course our hardware team.
...the same team that delivered...
...the unprecedented performance...
...with Xbox One X...
...is deep into architecting...
...the next Xbox consoles.
...where we will once again...
...deliver on our commitment...
...to set the benchmark...
...for console gaming.
...and let's talk about our games themselves.
...we are committed...
...to building an industry leading...
...first party studios organization.
...and as you saw earlier...
...we are making one of our greatest...
...single year investments in teams...
...by adding five new creative studios.
...we have committed our team...
...our company, our technical resources...
...so we can declare to you today...
...and next year...
...and all of the years after that...
...you will always...
...experience the best in gaming...
...only on Xbox.
...only on Xbox, ja genau.
...für alle Zeit...
...bis ans Ende aller Tage...
...da sind Wörter zu retten...
...Heroes zu erschaffen...
...und Legenden zu werden...
...together...
...Danke...
...und...
...gute Nacht.
Watch Dogs 3
Ich sag's euch, irgendwie sowas kommt da jetzt noch.
Oder hat Sombra gehackt?
Fuck, ist das wirklich Watch Dogs 3?
Windows-Seriennummern?
Ah!
Ist das, ist das CD Projekt Red?
Geralt hat sich aber ganz schön geändert.
Can't deny it, it's all true.
But everybody still wants to live here.
This city's always got a promise for you.
Might be a lie.
An illusion.
But it's there.
Just around the corner.
And it keeps you going.
It's a city of dreams.
And I'm a big dreamer.
Wussten was doch.
Man hat halt absolut
Null vom Gameplay gesehen.
Aber ich mein,
Ich glaub bisher hat man zu dem Spiel
gar nix gesehen.
Okay, ich glaub jetzt ist fertig.
Das ist der Outro-Trailer.
Also Leute,
Es war umwelten besser
als EA gestern.
Das muss man zugeben, oder?
Ich mein, es waren immerhin
paar geile Sachen dabei, muss man sagen.
Das neue Gears of War wird bestimmt nicht schlecht.
Das neue Tomb Raider bestimmt nicht schlecht.
Cyberpunk, mal gucken.
Phil Spencer hat ja gefühlt quasi
bei jedem seiner Ansprachen
immer das gleiche gesagt.
Wie committed und geil und
bis in alle Zeit Xbox und so.
Und committed
und best ever.
Ja, Halo gab's ja kurz.
Halo hat man halt ein bisschen was gesehen.
Ich fand's nicht übel, muss ich euch ehrlich sagen.
Allein schon, weil sie einfach gesagt haben,
Okay, auf geht's.
Games zeigen, bisschen gelabert.
Games zeigen, Games zeigen, Games zeigen,
bisschen gelabert. Games zeigen, Games zeigen.
Man kann jetzt natürlich sagen,
Okay, Microsoft hat insgesamt
vielleicht bisschen
wenig 2018.
Ich mein, es war, die großen Dinge
und die Sachen, wo man sagt, da kann man gehypt drauf
sein, die waren eigentlich alle
2019.
Aber insgesamt war das doch nicht schlecht.
So, wann kommt denn das nächste jetzt?
Ähm...
Upps!
Oh, jetzt geht die Porno-Musik
wieder los.
Ähm, haben wir das auch irgendwie in deutsch?
So, Termine, Pressekonferenz, was kommt denn als nächstes?
Bethesda kommt heute um 3 Uhr irgendwann, ne?
Oh ne, bis 3 bleibe ich nicht wach.
Ich glaube, PC Games hatte eine ordentliche Übersicht davon.
Alle Pressekonferenzen, Computerbilder, das mache ich nicht auf.
Das mache ich nicht auf.
Also Bethesda ist heute glaube ich um 3.30 Uhr, das ist mir ein bisschen zu spät.
Ja komm, wir gucken mal kurz, wann die nächsten Termine sind.
Ja, ja Bethesda ist heute Nacht.
Das Computerbild kann sich auch nicht so wirklich entscheiden, ne?
Ob der 10. Juni jetzt ein Montag ist oder ob der 10. Juni jetzt ein Sonntag ist.
Wohne hat mich aber nichts mehr bei der Zeitung.
Okay, morgen haben wir noch Square Enix zu bieten und Ubisoft.
Oh, Ubisoft 22 Uhr, das ist so spät.
Ich weiß nicht, ich muss ja Dienstag wieder früh aufstehen, um auf die Arbeit zu gehen.
Vielleicht machen wir Ubisoft 22 Uhr.
Vielleicht machen wir Ubisoft 22 Uhr morgen und wir gucken uns, würde ich sagen, im Laufe des Tages noch Bethesda und Digital Devolver, gucken wir uns noch an.
Können wir irgendwann morgen Mittag oder so gucken.
Hast du einen Link zu deinem Meme-Tool?
Ja, guck mal auf meinem GitHub-Profil.
Ich wollte noch wenigen klatschen.
Ach genau, ja, da gibt es nicht viel zu erzählen.
Wir waren mal Vorklatscher für Microsoft.
Auf der...
Nicht, dass ich das...
Wenn ich das vorher gewusst hätte, hätte ich mir das überlegt, ja.
Aber als ich da mal da gesessen habe, naja.
Wir wurden eingeladen.
Das war, glaube ich, auf der Gamescom 2016.
Im Prinzip ist es auch egal, welches Jahr das gewesen ist.
Oder 15.
Haben sie uns eingeladen von Microsoft.
Und ich dachte mir so, das ist nice, mal direkt vom Hersteller.
Das ist besser.
Da kannst du...
Super Platz, alles schon vorher und...
Super, ne?
Gehen wir hin.
Ich bin mit Felix da.
Und auf einmal kommen sie vorher schon an und erzählen uns dann so, wie super und toll das wird.
Und was für alles...
Danach dann auch, gibt es irgendwo kostenlos Essen und alles.
Die haben so ein übelst gutes Wetter gemacht.
Wir haben uns so gefragt, was ist mit denen los?
Irgendwie so...
Die sind so ultra freundlich.
Das stimmt doch irgendwas, ne?
Und irgendwann haben wir es dann gecheckt.
Und dann haben wir uns dann gecheckt.
Da haben sie uns nämlich alle so eine Tasche in die Hand gedrückt mit Zeugs drin.
Unter anderem Xbox-T-Shirts.
Grüne Xbox-T-Shirts.
Da stand sowas drauf, irgendwas in der Richtung wie...
Ähm...
I witnessed the greatest games of all times.
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Wir haben es ja heute gesehen.
Microsoft ist ja immer sehr bescheiden, was das angeht.
Und da wollten sie, dass wir uns alle die Xbox-T-Shirts anziehen.
Und da haben sie uns dann quasi schon vorher in diesen Raum...
Also in diesen Saal geschleust, wo die Pressekonferenz war.
Und in die erste Reihe gehockt.
Beziehungsweise in die ersten zwei Reihen.
Und da ist es dann gedämmert.
Nachdem sie dann auch angefangen haben, uns vorher ein bisschen anzuheizen mit Gelaber.
Ähm...
Ey, wir durften sogar Phil Spencer Fragen stellen.
Ja, haben sie uns ganz toll angekündigt.
Nur für die besten, für die tollsten Xbox-Fans und sowas.
Und bis es dann irgendwann gedämmert ist.
Die haben uns da vorne hingesetzt und so zugeschleimt.
Einfach, dass wir anklatschen.
Anklatschen.
Das habe ich aber...
Einfach nicht gecheckt.
Aber es war letztendlich doch nicht schlecht.
Sowas mal aus der ersten Reihe zu sehen, war ganz nice.
Also direkt vom Hersteller ist eh immer am besten.
Oder direkt vom Veranstalter.
Und jetzt habe ich ein schickes Xbox-T-Shirt.
Dass ich die Greatest Games of All Time gewitnessed habe.
Richtig Sellout, ja.
Und wir haben beim...
Beim Essen...
Danach, wo es...
Gab es gegenüber irgendeinen Burgerladen.
Da hat der Felix den echten Anklatscher...
Die echten Anklatscher von Microsoft entlarvt.
Da stand nämlich einer mit so einer grünen Xbox-Hose an.
Halt ohne Xbox-T-Shirt und so.
Also nicht mit dem Microsoft-T-Shirt, sondern mit diesem normalen Xbox-T-Shirt.
Und einer grünen Hose.
Und da meint so der Felix so...
Boah ey, du hast dich aber hier...
Du wusstest ja gar nicht, was so auf dich zukommt.
Du hast jetzt aber passende Hose dazu angezogen.
Es war schon mal Glück, dass das so gepasst hat, ne?
Und dann meint der Typ so...
Nee, nee, ich bin von Microsoft.
Die haben halt so ihre eigenen Leute dann drunter gemischt.
So nach dem Motto zum gehypt sein.
Aber ganz ehrlich, warum nicht?
Scheiß drauf.
Bisschen Hype muss sein.
Wenn da nicht gehypt wird, hypt ja sonst keiner.
Wie öffnet man das Meme-Tool?
Du brauchst Visual Studio und musst dir selbst kompilieren.
Da ist nur das Source-Code auf der Tab.
Es gibt noch kein offizielles Release davon.
Ja, Computer-Build, das machen wir jetzt mal wieder zu.
Ist ja eklig.
Ist auch so eklig wie Pilze auf dem PC.
Was ist das überhaupt? Lüfter?
Ah.
Ist auch so eklig wie Pilze auf dem Lüfter.
Nur eine Stelle, wo Pilze noch ekliger sind als auf dem Lüfter.
Aber da gehen wir jetzt nicht.
Da gehen wir uns nicht näher drauf ein.
Gut. Ich hoffe, euch hat das Streben gefallen.
Mal gucken, was wir morgen machen.
Wann wir anfangen. Morgen habe ich frei.
Ja, Samstag, Sonntag, Montag.
Bin ich immer am Start.
Ich könnte ja morgen mal mein
Real Royale
Wie heißt es da?
Crown Royale Gameplay hochladen auf YouTube.
Wie ich als Obernoob
die noch noobigere Noobs geblasht habe.
Redet irgendwie 22 Minuten.
Aber das Gameplay ist schlecht.
Ja, Leute. Schlaft gut. Macht's gut. Bis morgen. Tschüss.
Hast du den Overwatch League All Access Pass? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Macht's gut. Tschüss.
See you.